[Laughter]
little halloween laugh there to start it
off yeah yeah happy halloween happy
halloween
happy halloween jerking you jerking your
wien
yeah i'm jerking my mark wiens yeah yeah
have any of you recently been jerking
your wing to
aoc perhaps we have a we have a
we have a bomb on that bigger than than
pokeman
and what is it surprise she has a
boyfriend uh-oh
every every dude oh [ __ ] hey dude
what's left was like aoc has a boy
oh heading straight to that republican
ballot
[Laughter]
donating to her dude what the [ __ ] i was
so
my wife got so mad at me because i sold
our car and we donated it to her future
campaign as president yeah dude and i'm
like
gifted 500 subs during her among us
stream
just for what to be treated like this
yeah she's got a bf i have to call kyle
on this kyle's like there's a
there's a reason they don't they don't
tell anyone this [ __ ]
you know people are upset we just upset
so many dudes right now
yeah she has a boy i thought
hey you thought me eating ruined your
saturday yeah
happy saturday [ __ ]
wow 2020 is really weird
oh the chrono virus yeah aoc has a
boyfriend
wait what yeah bruh that dude
i thought i had a shot bro i mean i
can't believe she's dating a redditor
she really is this guy's guy's name
riley
roberts riley roberts ugh sounds like a
[ __ ] mod of the world news
subreddit sounds like a step-sister
underwear detective
nice yeah bro that beard is strong
yeah it's like at least a hundred hours
on world of warcraft yeah
minimum dog they don't know
and he doesn't even hold her hand in
public and true reddit or style man
this is some [ __ ] how do you think they
met what's the story
let's look it up um what's he do besides
mod some of the world's the most popular
subreddits yeah and and modify computers
i can't believe this guy is defined as
aoc's boyfriend
bruh hold on what is this now yeah at
least he's tall
how tall is aoc um okay
aoc height lc height
oh she's 5'4 oh okay so maybe not
yes based on this picture okay hold on
dude she got her little heels on
so that's like what two yeah three
inches yeah
so five six five seven he's probably
he's probably six feet
maybe i think he's like five ten five
eleven okay
still so we have a shot yeah exactly
yeah exactly
all the [ __ ] dudes right now figuring
it out okay okay okay
she's got red hair okay okay i know
that's the one thing she's like she was
a ginger
yeah she was a translucent dude yeah
that is
[Laughter]
she made a boyfriend bot he looks like
me
i guess you're saying i have a chance
bruh
this this drops this year they recently
got a dog together
this is creepy that we're doing this
yeah it's super creepy and i feel bad
too
i mean yeah bullying this guess random
dude i know
i know he didn't if they're what if
they're really happy you know yeah i
don't know how you could be happy with a
ginger but um
i bet they're happy and i bet i'm just
kidding to all the gingers out there
my first girlfriend ever was a ginger
alright yeah so there you go
i got nothing against him yeah but um
you couldn't tell anyone
at the time because you know dating and
ginger is like salem witch trials oh
yeah
you can't let anyone of course
significant other every ginger right now
is like what the [ __ ]
dude i'm trying to figure it i looked up
his job
and you know i didn't get an immediate
result because i don't read
that's so good job parents religion aoc
height just all the [ __ ] that everyone
googles
okay well that's good to know he's
supported good
good good dude he's like full like just
full redditer and just
i don't know why you're like in politics
takes way too much time away from me i
need sandwiches and gamer cookies babe
gamer cookies what's a gamer cookie um
you know like that little tick tock
where the girl like
you saw that shakes the wristband yeah
right right oh right right right it's
like healthy toothpaste on it
there's like little mayonnaise on the
[ __ ] yeah
ritz cracker your babe then he goes
mayonnaise with sprinkles on it
[Laughter]
gamer cookie dude [ __ ] the saw the
funniest dick talk yesterday
nuzzling up to his girlfriend like you
know like in her neck
yeah and she goes she goes oh and he
goes i
love my mommy she's filming it
and she's like yeah do you he's like
yeah i love my mommy so much
and then he looks up and sees the phone
he's like yo yo and he gets up he's like
what are you doing
and she's she's like what he's like you
can't film that
my boys don't know that i like talk to
you like that
is it you think it's real or it's fake
it kind of seemed like it was
fake but at the same time they acted it
really well and
okay like it just it was so funny that's
that's funny because i have a running
bit where anytime alina does tells me to
do something that's good for me
or does something nice for me i go
thanks mom yeah yeah just don't do that
yeah it's like i don't want to be your
mom i'm like all right mom
love you mommy yeah thank you so much
[Laughter]
that sounds real it sounds real
yo you can't film that
dude hey hold up distinct features
internet roast him how do they know 5
feet 11. you nailed it
dude what can i say you nailed it his
weight was listed as 178 pounds
81 kilograms after the release of
knocked down the house in may in 2019
twitter had a quote field day over
roberts looks
a uk-based political reporter
disrespected his scruffy appearance in
the documentary called him a bin
raccoon what the [ __ ] is that uh
you know trash panda that's that's the
american version it's like a raccoon
you know they go diving for trash i
really don't think that's good
bin raccoon sounds like an insult it's
i mean it's an insult but i don't think
it's very good like you know oh you
don't think it's a good insult
no or you don't think this guy has been
in raccoon like there are people that
have been raccoons
yeah for sure yeah and this guy's
probably not one of them
it doesn't fit me as no no wi-fi
reception in the bin
no no
i'm just thinking now english people get
away like
if an american says ben raccoon it's not
good like english people
are just like they're like
the english accent is the you know re
camera
of accents you know you could shoot dog
[ __ ] on an ari but it's a lot you know
as long as it's re it's beautiful and it
always ends up being a good
thing yeah like you know every insult is
good
yeah you know someone calls you like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're like
thank you yeah yeah like wow hey
i've never had anyone talk to me like
that that's
bloody bin raccoon you grafting
are you grafting are you grafting me
mate are you grafting me mate
you